[Applause]
all right I'm gonna match you notebook
for notebook oh I'm gonna run out of
hands but that's all right so I was
sitting listening to the life in other
places and and and the bottom up power
of Wikimedia and I wondered whether we
ought to talk about how to make life
better here and and it made me think
about the election that we're in you you
among other things are putting future
and futurism and designed together and
talk about anticipatory democracy right
yeah that's not that's a ton that Alvin
Toffler I think coined you've been doing
such one of the things we have in common
is both of us coming up to the edge of
the limits of the scenario methodology
invented a while ago done it in
different ways and I'm very fascinated
with this these experiments you've been
doing so have you done anything yet in
in in a way that really has come up to
the edge of getting people to do things
differently yeah I would say so I mean
well I have attempted to yeah prior to
moving to the Bay Area about a year ago
I lived in Hawaii and worked for the
Hawaii Research Center for future
studies which was set up in 1971 by a
gentleman named Jim data who still
directs it and the history of the
organization is sort of interesting
because it was established at the end of
a year and a half long process called
Hawaii 2000 that was run in 1970-71 I
think for about 18 months and it was the
single largest broadest based most
participate exercise in futuring in
foresight ever held anywhere so Hawaii
2000 1970 looking 30 years ahead and the
HR CFS as I'll call it was set up at the
end of that now the sad kind of coda to
this myth to that process oh and I mean
I forgot to mention you
Toffler was brought out arthur c clarke
the good and the great were you know
future thinkers of the time were were
participating in this and hawaii had
only been a state for ten years at that
point so it was a very promising kind of
early signal that they were interested
in institutionalizing a forward view now
sadly what happened was in 1973 there
was an oil crisis and in effect a lot of
that that forward thinking was shelved
in favor of crisis management and it
never really made its way back into the
political process so by the time the
year 2000 came around what had actually
eventuated in hawaii was one of the
worst case scenarios that people had
imagined in in 1970 so I started there
five years later
2005 and at the end of that year the
state government approached us at the
futures center and said we'd like to
have a statewide conversation about the
future you know deja vu but this time we
want to we want to base it the
conversation around sustainability and
we will make the focal point the time
horizon 2050 and so in 2005 this kind of
planning process began in 2006 it was
kicked off now I'm getting to the answer
of your question which was we realized
that that involving people in a
discussion of the relatively far future
several decades out is not where most of
us spend most of our day and it's a it's
it's a it's a complex and difficult
thing to get people who have urgent
issues they have kids to feed they have
jobs to do they have meetings to make it
to and the multidecadal timeline future
is not generally on the table so we had
to find a way to make it compelling make
it concrete make it present to people
and so I think the experiments are one
of them that you're referring to was an
attempt by myself and Jake Dunnigan
who's an our Institute for the future in
Palo Alto to to stage what we called
experiential scenario
so a series of immersive experiences
that evoked well that has sort of
attempted to roleplay in essence for
different versions of the year 2050 that
people could could spend time in and
then discuss their future you know their
priorities their expectations on the
basis of a far more visceral and bodily
and lived sense of the variety of
futures on offer so I mean and I'd say
that that is sort of trying to push
things and there was a prankster quality
to it to some of it too so which of it
worked the best
well the pranksta III like the history
of the word Ken Kesey and the Merry
Pranksters and you know I think there's
one in the room right right but but yeah
the connotations can be difficult to
basically the that process the 2051 in
in some ways failed to be
institutionalized effectively as well I
mean a sustainability plan was produced
you can find it online but there's
nothing particularly compelling about it
and as far as I know you know life in
Hawaii has not been revolutionized it's
nice to see that it has come you know
some distance in terms of environmental
awareness some of the basic things like
recycling programs and things but but
basically the the process wasn't
although the intervention that we held
for 2050 was a great success as compared
to your standard workshop process the
larger agenda of which it was a part was
not an overwhelming success
unfortunately and so it was with some
reluctance that Jake and I turned to
well reluctance but excitement actually
because there was there was a lot of
interesting potential there that we
turned to bringing futures into people's
everyday lives whether they had asked
for them or not so we would send them
postcards from alternative
of the Year 2036 or there was a project
we conducted in Chinatown Honolulu where
posters and various artifacts from
alternative versions of Chinatown in the
future were sort of plastered in the
streets for people who stumble across
during their lunch hour which was more
successful I think there are pros and
cons to both the kind of contained
setting of a workshop unknown
participant base all that kind of thing
compared to trying to address people
directly in the middle of their you know
in the middle of their day when they
haven't asked for it but I think the
latter is needed because the because not
enough people are opting into the former
and to having conversations about
futures you know for all the you know
one of the things that I feel I first
went to work at gbn with Peter and
Stuart and 95 and I think that was about
the same time along now was was getting
going right and I think in the the
attention span and the way in which
things have sped up is has gotten a lot
worse in that period of time so I mean
the inspiring sense of you know if you
can get people to think about the long
term you a better chance of getting to
do the right thing which was a you know
part of the purpose that got me to go to
gbn in the first place I just think
that's getting harder and harder and
harder to do instead of you know without
despite all the wonderful things that
have been done and are happening and I
really do wonder what and and I think of
it you know in terms of our of our
politics so we think about you know
democracy not in the wikimedia case but
in what we're on this you know it's just
it's like how do we get people to engage
in something larger
rather than shorter term and and more
narrow you know it just seems like it's
getting harder and harder and so I was
really I was just really interested in
some of the experiments that you that
you were doing I mean I I got I for me
with scenarios the the thing that I kept
running into was the
the way the point at which the scenarios
met the human system that had to act on
them and and often the great break down
between no matter what perceptions or
ideas people had come just sort of the
the sheer reality about the
implementation of insights and of course
the people who you know started working
on that at Shell knew that from the
beginning but but it's what I've spent
minute much of the last years doing is
trying to move into systems where the
issues of the what I would think of as
the human and organizational and
financial sustainability questions of
how you get institutions and human
communities to hold the long term you
know what what does that look like and I
think that's one that one of the other
really interesting experiments about
long now not just how do we build this
clock that's gonna last but you know how
you build an organization that could
maintain it you know and and all the
rest all right
I'm interested I have a lot I have a lot
of questions about that I'm not sure
have any answers but I'm curious about
what your what your role think I mean it
seems to me that one of the it makes a
lot of difference I've noticed based it
makes a lot of difference to how people
understand what they think you're doing
based on whether you introduce yourself
as being a future a futurist a futures
person or you know risk management
person I don't think of my work in those
terms but that is much easier for people
to understand strategic management no
problem you know that serious work
thanks tur yeah well there's that too
but I and foresight is actually more
readily understood by people you know I
think of those terms as almost
interchangeable foresight being the
capacity and futures alternative futures
being the subject matter which the
foresight is kind of exercised on if you
like but but if you talk about your work
as being futures work or being a
futurist it seems to import boatloads of
connotations and
which are largely unhelpful to the
composite to actually getting people to
to think about the future and to think
of things in terms of alternatives and
and so you know it's become clear to me
that it's that it's important to to
recognize that that this perspective you
know the longer-term and the multiple
scenario perspective that one has to
offer needs to be seen as part of an
array of tools that people bring to
whatever task it is that they're doing
you know if you if you allow yourself to
be typecast as the person who who is
always and only constantly advocating
you know the the 10,000 year view then
there's going to be a massive disconnect
but what's actually called for is sort
of it's more of a long zoom type of idea
where you're acknowledged you'll see you
can see things in the present for you
know what they are or what they appear
to be and then just sort of assume the
perspective of the longer term in
addition to that and and to be able to
alternate between how things look from
here and how things look you know 10 20
50 however many is appropriate years out
but not to kind of not to be understood
as trying to supplant people's current
understandings because that doesn't work
yeah you have to start from start very
much from understanding where they are
and why it is that they feel the way
they do it's so one thing I was curious
about you said that you found yourself
sort of coming up against the limits of
scenario thinking and scenarios as a
method can you can you say more about
what some of those limits are and how
you've tried to work around them well so
I think the first one I already talked
about that I got more and more
interested in the organizations and
human beings and and how it is to help
people change and help organizations
change and took my work in that
direction even when I was working in the
scenario but I had a very interesting
opportunity that I was given too
take the methodology that had been
developed in business mostly and
experiment with it very intensively in
nonprofits and philanthropy over a
period of years and it was fascinating I
found that the business people were much
better at taking a set of alternative
futures and stepping back and saying you
know well we could do this in this
future and this in this future and this
in this future over here because in fact
they were doing it for the most part
about they could make money and they
could make money in any future and one
was more challenging than the other but
it was but if you took if you did that
same thing with a group of people who've
just spent 20 years or 30 years invested
in trying to bring a certain future
about you could sometimes literally
watch their body align you know they
just would go in the corner and start
doing this you just couldn't you know it
was it was too hard it was too
threatening because actually some of
those futures would fundamentally
destroy their life's work right and so
the fact that you could actually go live
in that future and learn something and
actually invent a better strategy to
bring about the thing that that was
their life work rice work was really
really too hard and so I began to
experiment with and try to understand
how how to you know how to how to work
with some of those ideas and tools and
in different ways and and because I do
think that we're in a moment where you
know we have to innovate we have to
innovate radically across across many
many things and so especially for people
you know I feel it's myself as you get
older all the things that got you to
where you are now or not the things
you're gonna need to succeed moving
ahead and so part of the job is to take
the leader and shake them up enough that
that you know without being threatened
or you know that you did you can open up
and and and see the things that you know
10 or 20 years ago might have been
unthinkable to you that might actually
be the thing you need to do now I think
that fear that you refer to is a really
interesting piece of this
kind of work and once it's articulated
or you know once you're able to talk
about it it's a whole different
conversation than than the fear which
prevents the conversation from happening
in the first place yeah yeah prevents
the examination of the future end of you
know especially the scary ones in which
your life to work amounts to nothing or
you know it's exactly my favorite thing
that I think I've ever read or heard
about organizational change was the the
great organizational theorists Edgar
Schein sat down with Harvard Business
Review after spending you know decades
studying all this and they said to him
okay you know what did you learn in 50
years of research and he said well it
really just was one thing and that is
that people don't people in
organizations don't change until their
fear of survival exceeds their fear of
learning so you know mostly it's so hard
to learn and it's so scary that you have
to have this kind of threat and and I
you know I feel like actually we just
live through the last 10 years of we
actually wasted two major crises in the
world I mean I will never forgive George
Bush for many things but the thing I'll
absolutely never forgive him for is that
he could have asked us to do anything in
this country anything when you said two
crises I thought you meant the first
election and the second one but anyway
yeah 9/11 in the and then I think Obama
failed to ask enough of of the moment
that he inherited right and you know so
there is something about that sort of
moment of fear and when your survival is
in play and the problem with so many of
these long-term things that we face in
this context of time is that we don't
experience them in a way that seems to
threaten our survival right I mean and
that's the point of doing experiential
scenarios and bringing it bringing it
out in people is that there is a
fundamentally emotional component to
this kind of work which has to do with
kind of well you know in this book
switch chip yes yes when they talk about
the rider and the elephant yes the you
know that's their metaphor for yes two
sides of the of the psychological system
the rational and the emotional and and
you have to motivate the elephant as
well as you know persuade the rider in
order to move in the desired direction
and so I mean I think that translating
futures work and scenarios into
experiences that people can have is a
way of bringing these things out you
know and it might scare the hell out of
the elephant to do that but but a calm a
hypothetical conversation like that is
the safe space where you can go through
those things I mean rather than waiting
for the crisis to happen one thing that
we said you know in response to the
prankster newspaper coverage of some of
the the interventions we did in the
public was that you know it's better to
be surprised by a simulation than
blindsided by reality because the
simulation can't hurt you if you wait
until the reality you know hits you over
the head and you move into crisis mode
well yeah it's a lot politically it's a
lot easier to defend because look
there's a crisis it's it's really
self-evident but you've already lost the
opportunity to actually move proactively
towards the future that you want and you
know also crisis can be waged as you've
just suggested I've missed the moment to
ask you what your next experiment is so
I guess we're gonna have to all find out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you